[Music]
Selena Gomez and the weekend continue to
be inseparable I'm a really happy place
I'm good we hope a Belle Lena is here to
stay
et has a rundown of all the reasons why
we can't get enough of the cute couple
[Music]
it's only been a few months but the two
appear to be crazy in love I can see it
in your eyes it was clear the pop star
only had eyes for the weekend when they
made their red carpet debut at the 2017
Met Gala inside the pair was spotted
packing on the PDA even sneaking in a
sweet smooch let me show you how good
well Selena isn't the only one who
thinks the weekend is good for her mom
Andy gives her stamp of approval she
commented on the pig the star boy singer
shared of the pair that red glowing
smiling mama is happy enjoying my life
and I'm getting to do things that I'm
passionate about with the people that I
love from adorably cheering on her
boyfriend in concert to romantic date
nights including a trip to Toronto in
the weekend hometown and who could
forget when they became Instagram
official Selena posted this pic cold
chillin at Coachella in trendy Sunny's
Selena and the weekend make our hearts
melt and if you're as obsessed as we are
leave your comments and head over to ET
online for the latest
you